-Well, here's what people
are talking about.
You guys, we are just three days
away from Super Bowl LII.
That is right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Which means
that we're just three days away
from finding out whether Boston
will be burned down
by an angry mob or a happy mob.
We don't know which --
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Everyone is excited.
In fact, I saw that on StubHub,
there's a Super Bowl ticket
listed at over $66,000.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
And the person who buys
it will get to the stadium
and say, "$10 for a beer?
That's crazy. Come on, man."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"What am I doing here?
I should be watching the game."
Over on the Animal Planet,
they're holding their
14th annual Puppy Bowl.
And -- yeah.
-Yeah!
-This year,
it will feature Team Ruff...
[ Light laughter ]
...versus Team Fluff.
[ Laughter ]
And if you're curious
which team is better,
please visit
www.gamblersanonymous.org.
They're here to help.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
"Blew $66,000 on Team Fluff."
[ Laughter ]
"$10 for a beer?!
Come on, man!"
[ Laughter ]
"There's no way they're not
starting that puppy in Fluff!"
[ Laughter ]
If that's not enough, though,
Sunday is also the Kitten Bowl
on the Hallmark Channel.
-What?
[ Cheering ]
It'll feature
the Little Longtails
going up against their rival,
a red laser pointer.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Speaking of TV, guys,
I saw that Omarosa
is going to be a cast member
on "Celebrity Big Brother."
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
She said that,
after a year in the White House,
she just wanted to be in a house
without so much drama.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some more news
out of Washington.
I read that the government is
spending $24 million
to replace two refrigerators
on Air Force One.
Until then,
they're keeping perishables cold
by putting them
between Donald and Melania.
-Hey-oh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Whoa! Whoa! Ho!
-That's using your noggin.
That's using your brain.
That's using
your noggin right there.
-Hey!
-I heard about
this new trend on Twitter.
Did you guys hear about this?
It's where people lip-synch
a quote from "Riverdale,"
then they throw up a scarf,
and they transform.
Have you heard of this?
It's pretty fun.
Check this out.
-Oh, well.
karma's a bitch.
-Whoa! Yeah.
Now, Tariq, you were telling me
that you did one earlier, yeah?
-Yeah, yeah.
Check it out.
-Oh, well.
Karma's a bitch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ] What?
[ Laughter ]
That is really --
That is really something
right there.
-Check out mine, Jimmy.
-Oh, well.
Karma's a bitch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my goodness.
Whoa, whoa, wow.
Wow, wow, wee wow.
Incredible.
Hey, James, you did one,
too, right?
-Yeah, watch this.
-Oh, well.
Karma's a bitch.
-Oh!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
That's your --
James, that's your -- that's
your one solo album from 2001.
[ Laughter ]
Unbelievable.
-Wow, that's a great change.
-Karma really is --
Happy birthday, by the way.
Happy belated birthday, James.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-We love -- We love you, man.
We love --
We love you.
We love you, man.
Oh, he had no idea.
I love it.
[ Laughter ]
We love you, dude.
Happy birthday, Stro, as well.
Happy belated birthday to Stro.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Happy birthday.
Listen to this.
You guys hear about this?
A man in Massachusetts went to
claim a $10,000 lottery prize
and found out
that he misread the ticket
and actually
won a million dollars.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Later, his wife said,
"Did you get the 10 grand?"
He was like, "Yes."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Yeah,
I got the whole 10 grand."
And finally, you guys,
I read that
the last Blockbuster location
in Texas is closing.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
When employees
were told the news, they said,
"Wait. We were still open?"
[ Laughter ]
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots!